- [Narrator] The race to be
the next speaker of the House
is down to these two.
Jim Jordan is known for
being a fiery attack dog
in his committees.
- I don't want you to answer my question.
The American people want Dr.
Fauci to answer the question.
- [Narrator] And being a
frequent voice on "Fox News."
- The left is, you know, their
religion is climate change.
- [Narrator] Steve Scalise,
while he spends less
time in the spotlight,
became a national figure after being shot
practicing for the congressional
baseball game in 2017.
- Both Republican and
Democrat reached out.
It really does show the
warm side of Congress
that very few people get to see.
- [Narrator] And is popular in his party
for his career and leadership,
building consensus among members.
Here's how these two charted
a course to the speakers race,
and how they represent two different paths
for the future of House Republicans.
Jordan actually got his first
vote for speaker back in 2013.
- [Reading Clerk] Jordan of Ohio.
- [Narrator] It was more of a protest vote
against then Speaker John Boehner
as were the two votes he
got again two years later.
- Jordan. Jordan.
- [Narrator] That year,
the majority leader
lost his election and Kevin
McCarthy moved up from whip
to the number two position,
and a new face joined
the leadership, Scalise.
- We're gonna continue to
move forward in the House
as a united team.
- [Narrator] At the same
time, Jordan co-founded
the anti-establishment
House Freedom Caucus,
made up of more conservative
members of the House
angry Republican priorities
were not making it into negotiations
with the Democratic
White House and Senate.
They ultimately pushed
Boehner to resign that fall.
- Well, are they unrealistic
about what can be done in government?
That's the dysfunction.
- Absolutely, they're unrealistic.
- [Narrator] Jordan's caucus
also blocked McCarthy from moving up,
electing Paul Ryan after
forcing McCarthy to drop out.
- I think I shocked some of you, huh.
- [Narrator] And Jordan
later challenged McCarthy
for the role of leader.
He lost.
So when the speakership opened up again,
McCarthy moved up, but not
without some protest votes.
- Jim Jordan.
- [Reading Clerk] Jordan.
- [Narrator] And Scalise
moved up to leader.
- As the majority leader,
I really look forward to
bringing those bills to the floor
through a committee
process that's open again.
- [Narrator] But while their paths
to the speaker battle have differed,
their backgrounds are remarkably similar.
They both represent their hometowns
and win reelection easily.
They both started their political
careers at the same time
and around the same age
as state representatives
and eventually senators
before becoming Congressmen
also around the same time.
Politically, they're
both very conservative
and both supported Trump's efforts
to overturn the 2020 election.
- Do you think the election was stolen?
- And it's not just irregular.
It's states that did
not follow the laws set
which the Constitution says
they're supposed to follow.
- 80 million Americans, 80
million of our fellow citizens,
Republicans and Democrats, have
doubts about this election.
- [Narrator] Although
Jordan is much closer
to Trump personally.
- There's so many weak Republicans,
and we have great ones.
Jim Jordan and some of these guys,
they're out there fighting,
the House guys are fighting.
- [Narrator] January 6th wasn't Jordan's
first brush with controversy.
In 2018, former Ohio
State University students
from Jordan's time as an
assistant wrestling coach
claimed he knew about sexual
abuse by the team doctor,
but Jordan has denied this.
While they have a lot in common,
the primary difference between the two
is in their beliefs of how to utilize
their slim Republican
majority in Congress.
Scalise is pitching himself as the one
with the experience and
personal relationships
from his time in leadership to
bring party members together.
- I've got a long proven record
as somebody who knows
how to unify Republicans
to fight on the battles that matter
for the families who
gave us this majority.
- [Narrator] Although
he's currently battling
a blood cancer he says is very treatable.
- If the doctors didn't sign
off, I wouldn't be doing this.
- [Narrator] Jordan,
however, is pitching himself
as the person who could unite
the more far right members of the party
who are frustrated Republican priorities
are again left out of negotiations.
- I do think we have to have someone
who can bring our team together.
I think I'm best equipped to do that.
- [Narrator] So House
Republicans will have to decide.
Do they finally give the rebel a try
or stick with the established successor?
(gentle music)